the Nays are 210 the resolution is
adopted without objection the motion to
reconsider is laid on the table the
office of Speaker of the House of the
United States House of Representatives
is hereby declared
vacant that is a stunner you have never
seen what you see unfolding now in The
Well of the house uh in American history
okay now to be perfectly honest with you
I don't really care about this at all I
don't I don't care who the speaker of
the house is I'm a terrible conservative
pundit because I should be totally
fascinated by the story it's historic
it's histor it is historic it's the
first time in American history but I
really don't care